some of the reason why adult life can be
grayer
and more miserable than it should be is
that our earliest years
are generally made up of a prolonged and
highly formative encounter
with the idea of obedience throughout
childhood
there is little doubt that the path to
maturity must involve
doing a litany of substantially
unpleasant things
demanded of us by figures of authority
whom we cannot question
no one asks if we would be particularly
interested in learning about the
angles of triangles or what a vault
really is
but we obey in any case we give over our
days and much of our evenings and
weekends to complying with an agenda
elaborated for us
by people whose concern with our
happiness is at best
highly abstract we put on our blue or
grey jumper
and sit at a desk and study the plot
line of macbeth or the chemical
properties of helium
and trust that our boredom and distaste
must be substantially
wrong we then become inclined to extend
this attitude into our dealings with the
wider world
we assume that what we particularly want
should never be the important factor
we opt for a career on the basis that to
others
it looks like the right thing to
subscribe to at parties
we'll be able to answer the question
what do you do
in a way that by consensus is
unobjectionable or somewhat impressive
at the same time we learn to see freedom
as both appealing
and in a way absurd we'll be free we
feel
when we don't have anything else to fill
our time with on saturday mornings or
when we're finally retired in the
process
we become highly adept at rationalizing
our frustrations
we tell ourselves that we have no option
we have to stick with a job that we
resent
or a marriage that's grown stale because
we say
we need the money or our friends would
be disappointed or it's the kind of
thing everyone like us
has to do we become geniuses at
elaborating excuses
that make our unhappiness look necessary
and sane the mid 20th century british
psychoanalyst donald winnicott
encountered many patients often
high-performing and prestigious ones
who were in acute distress because they
were as he put it
too good they had never felt the inner
freedom and security to say
no largely because their earliest
caregivers
would have viewed the expression of
their authentic feelings as a
threatening
insurrection that they had to quash
winnicott proposed
that health could only come about from
counteracting this tendency
to subordinate too quickly and too
trustingly
to the preferences of others including
people
who might claim to care a lot about us
being
bad in a salutary way in winnicott's
vision wouldn't have to mean breaking
the law or becoming aggressive
it would mean finding the inner freedom
to do things that others might find
disconcerting on the basis that we
our authentic selves have a sincere wish
to explore them
it would be founded on a very profound
view that others can never ultimately be
the best custodians of our lives
because their instincts about what's
acceptable haven't been formed on the
basis of a deep knowledge
of our unique needs
we tend to fantasize about freedom in
terms of not having to work or of being
able to take off on long trips
but if we dig into its core freedom
really means
no longer being beholden to the
expectations of
others we may quite freely work very
hard
or stay at home during the holidays the
decisive factor is our willingness to
disappoint
to upset or to disconcert others in
doing so
we don't need to relish this we may by
nature be inclined to get on well with
as many people as possible
but we can live with the idea that our
central choices
might not meet with general approval at
the party
we can risk someone not being at all
impressed by what we do
or regarding our living arrangements as
unorthodox
or our opinions as odd but we don't mind
too much
because we've become free
our sense of what our life is about is
no longer so confused
with the notion of meeting the
expectations
of others to be free ultimately is to be
devoted
in ways that might be strenuous to
meeting
our own expectations
how to overcome your childhood is a book
that teaches us how character is
developed
the concept of emotional inheritance the
formation of our concepts of being good
or bad
and the impact of parental styles of
love on the way we choose adult partners
you